MARY GROVE: Hi
everyone, good morning,
and thank you so
much for joining us.
My name is Mary Grove
and I'm the director
of Google for Entrepreneurs,
and it is my pleasure
to introduce our special
guest, Secretary Hank Paulson.
He served as the 74th
Secretary of the Treasury
during the Bush
administration, and prior to
that he spent over 20
years at Goldman Sachs,
where he eventually became
the Chief Executive Officer.
He began his career at the
Pentagon as a staff assistant
to the Assistant
Secretary of Defense,
and spent a year as well working
for the Nixon administration.
Secretary Paulson is the subject
of a newly released documentary
film called "Hank: 5
Years from the Brink,"
which chronicles his tenure as
Treasury Secretary from 2006-9
during the US financial
crisis, an unprecedentedly
difficult time.
Following his service
as Treasury Secretary,
he launched and continues
to work full time
as the Chairman of the Paulson
Institute at the University
of Chicago, a think
and do tank, working
to advance global
environmental protection
and sustainable economic growth
between the US and China.
Mr. Secretary,
welcome to Google.
HANK PAULSON: Well Mary,
thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
I'd say thank you all.
This is my first visit
to Google and thank you
for what you're all doing.
You're making a positive
difference in many,
many people's lives
every day, so thank you.
MARY GROVE: It really
is an honor to have you,
and congratulations on the
launch of the documentary film.
I found it riveting and
really, really insightful,
and it's called "Hank:
5 Years from the Brink."
Is it OK if I call you Hank?
HANK PAULSON: It sure is.
It's strange if you don't.
MARY GROVE: Great.
Well I'd love for you to
talk a bit about your path
to Treasury, and you said
that when you graduated
from Dartmouth, you wanted
to be a forest ranger.
And you ended up instead
starting at the Pentagon,
eventually going
to Goldman Sachs,
eventually becoming the
Chief Executive Officer.
Can you talk a little bit
about your career path?
HANK PAULSON: Well first
of all, some people
have got it all
planned out in advance,
but I'm always a bit
suspicious of career engineers.
I always said that
when I was recruiting
at Goldman Sachs, if someone
came out of their mother's womb
knowing they wanted to
be an investment banker,
I was deeply suspicious.
[LAUGHTER]
But with me whatever
I'm doing at the time
seemed very important,
and I would focus on that,
and I would tend not
to look that far ahead.
And I was an English major.
I took a lot of math courses.
I was an English major.
I actually had thought
that I might be a professor
or write books and as it turned
out, I took a different course.
I ended up at--
there was the Vietnam
War was going on at the time.
I ended up working
in the Pentagon,
and when I was in the
Pentagon I learned
that I liked working
on projects and I
did financial
analysis pretty well.
And so I ended up, when
I left government--
one of the things I
learned in government
was almost as important as what
you do is do you do it with.
And I worked for five
or six different people.
I had the same
strengths or weaknesses.
I found that a couple
of bosses really
appreciated what I did it
and were very helpful to me,
and so when I picked
Goldman Sachs,
Goldman Sachs was not the
top investment banking
firm in those days.
It probably didn't rank
in the top seven or eight,
but I really liked
the people I met with,
and it sort of seems
silly right now,
but I was convinced that I would
never have to live in New York.
I could--
MARY GROVE: You were
in Chicago, right?
HANK PAULSON: --live in
Chicago, and so I picked it,
and it was basically
the people I met.
People that you
might know of, like
Bob Rubin and Steve Friedman
and some of the other people
that were there.
And it was-- and
again I wasn't looking
to go back to government.
MARY GROVE: So on
that note, in the film
you talked about-- I found it
so interesting that you were
offered the position of
the Treasury three times
in the spring of 2006
before you accepted.
So was that a really
difficult decision to go back
into the public sector,
and ultimately what
made you change your mind?
HANK PAULSON: Well it
was a strange thing,
because I found I was-- when
I was running Goldman Sachs,
I'd go speak to business
schools all the time.
And I'd say welcome change,
change is your friend.
And of course human
beings always say that,
but most people really
don't like change.
And I had been-- I liked
my job at Goldman Sachs.
I very, very much enjoyed
doing what I was doing.
My family were not big fans
of the Bush administration,
to put it mildly, and so I
twice had turned it down.
And just before-- the second
time I turned it down,
I had-- it was just before I was
at the White House for a lunch
that President Bush was having
for President Hu of China.
And as we were walking out--
it was a beautiful May day,
and I looked out toward
the Treasury Building.
And I remembered
the one year when
I was working in the
Nixon White House,
I'd spent time going over to
see George Shultz, his Treasury
Secretary, and my wife could see
I was sort of in deep thought.
And so she said
to me, well Hank,
I sure hope you didn't turn down
the job because of me, because
of course, if it was
really important to you,
I would have agreed to do it.
And I said, yeah,
yeah, of course not.
And I took that as permission.
And so--
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: I thought
you were going
to say that you told her
you had suffered already.
HANK PAULSON: And so
then, when they came back
the third time, which
really shocked me,
it occurred to me
that the reason
I had said no the first
two times was fear.
And that I knew I was doing
what I was doing quite well.
And I couldn't think
of many people that
had gone to Washington
for a cabinet job that
left with a higher reputation
than they came with.
And so as soon as that hit me,
the last thing I wanted to do
was to give into that.
So I immediately
reversed myself, said yes
and it really ended
up shocking Wendy
because I didn't talk to her the
third time before I went back.
But in any event, it
was a-- and I'm really,
really glad I did it.
When I think back what an honor
it is to serve your country--
and I'm very glad
I was there, even
though during that horrible
time-- that how close
I came to not being there.
MARY GROVE: Absolutely.
And you said that you
predicted that at some point
during the Bush
administration there
would be a financial crisis.
Did you take the position going
in sort of eyes wide open?
What made you think that
a crisis was looming?
HANK PAULSON: Well Mary,
the very first meeting
I had with the president and
his economic advisors was
at Camp David, and I was asked
to speak on entitlement reform,
and-- which is one
of the reasons why
I'm going to Washington.
And I said, Mr.
President I'd like
to speak about
something else instead.
And I just said I
see so many excesses,
and they've been
going on for some time
and I think we're overdue
for a financial crisis.
I'd watched them come
every eight to ten years.
And when he said to me, what
do you think would cause it?
I said I don't know sir.
But with 20/20 hindsight,
later it'll be obvious.
I didn't see the
Russian default.
I didn't see some of
these other things.
So I talked about
credit default swaps,
I talked about a
complicated securities.
I never once mentioned mortgages
and residential home prices.
And as I said, I
think the reason
so many of us missed it--
you could see excesses there,
but ever since World War II,
if you look at housing prices
the US, it going up.
There hadn't been any
big nationwide decline
in residential home prices.
So if you owned a diversified
pool of mortgages,
the biggest risk you
worried about was you
would get your
money back to soon.
It wasn't that you'd
get-- rates would drop,
people would prepay.
And so we hadn't seen that.
But I was glad we focused on the
problem generally of a crisis,
because we started work
right away in preparing,
and so it gave me a great
chance to build relationships
with Ben Bernanke
and Tim Geithner.
And I actually had started,
got to know and build
a strong relationship
with Barney Frank,
because right away in
2006 we were working
on reforming Fannie and Freddie.
We didn't get it done, but
it took them about ready
to go down in June of 2008.
But at least it was,
I think, important
that I had a year
before the crisis
to build some of
the relationships.
MARY GROVE: So "5 Years from
the Brink," also the title
of the film.
Was there a specific
moment of the crisis
that you would call the
pinnacle, or the brink,
ranging from the beginning
with Bear Stearns all
the way through Lehman Brothers?
Is there actually a
palpable brink for you?
HANK PAULSON: Well I would
say if I looked at the week,
and there were some--
from mid-August,
where we were racing to
stabilize Fannie or Freddie,
and you remember they're
nine times bigger
than Lehman Brothers.
And can you imagine
if they'd failed,
or if we hadn't had mortgage
funding during the crisis
where real estate
prices would have been?
So it seemed like right
up from mid-August
through mid-October, when we
put the capital in the banks,
that whole period was
particularly difficult.
But I think the time that I
saw things like the clearest,
and how close we
were to disaster,
was-- we had what I call
Lehman Brothers weekend,
where we had Merrill Lynch,
AIG and Lehman Brothers
all going down at the same time.
And we didn't have a
single legal authority
that we could find that
would work for a Lehman.
And it turns, if you look
back at it, if B of A
had bought Lehman then
Merrill would have gone.
And it would've been worse.
But that week-- and so during
that week after Lehman went
down and where we
went up for the TARP ,
the time when I saw it the
clearest was when the money
market funds started, the run
generally started on money
market funds.
And 30 million Americans
had $3.5 trillion
in the money market funds.
But the linkage which
we had not focused on
was the money market funds were
funding commercial paper, which
many of the biggest
industrial companies used
to meet their financing needs.
So I received a call that
week from a CEO of a AAA
company-- AAA consumer products
company-- said that his CFO had
called him and said,
boss we may not
be able to make
it a $800 million
quarterly dividend
payment on our stock.
And the commercial paper
markets started to freeze,
and I could just
see as plain as day
what was going to happen if
big companies couldn't pay
their suppliers, and the CFO
was calling him up, saying boss,
we may not be able to--
we may have to stretch out
our pay-ables, cut back
on our inventories.
And then you look-- they don't
pay the smaller companies,
and as that ripples through
and you get all these layoffs
and failures going from
Wall Street to Main Street.
I mean I could see
what we were facing,
and I think we came very
close several times.
MARY GROVE: A few
brinks, so to speak.
HANK PAULSON: A few brinks.
MARY GROVE: So your wife Wendy
is profiled in the documentary
as well, and you allow us
a lovely and personal peek
into your relationship.
There's this great
anecdote where,
when you were just becoming more
established at Goldman Sachs,
you came home one day with a
beautiful expensive new winter
coat from Bergdorf Goodman,
and she tells you, Hank, you
already have a perfectly
fine coat, and you return it.
These wonderful stories
of-- she was definitely
is a source of strength
for you in tough times.
I'd love to know
what kept you calm
and focused during the crisis.
HANK PAULSON: Well first
of all on the documentary,
you keep saying,
you gave us a look.
Bloomberg did this, and at
the time-- I look at it now
and I'm happy with the
result, because I think
it gives you a sense of
what we were dealing with
and figures out how to tell
a complex story in ways
it's readily understandable.
And there's the human
side to it, also.
But at the time, I didn't
have an editorial control,
and the documentarian-- it
took a lot to persuade Wendy.
Wendy voted against doing the
documentary to begin with,
and so she showed
up and she finally
agreed to do it
three days before,
and showed up and
made her contribution.
But yeah, this is-- I would
just say something to all of you
here.
And it's probably as important
as anything I can say,
is that I don't know
any-- I've worked
with a lot of important
people, a lot of CEOs,
a lot of successful former
heads of state, heads of state--
and I don't know of
any one who says,
gee, I'm happy because
I had a great career
but I screwed up
my personal life.
I don't know anybody--
and there are
plenty of people that don't have
quite the career they'd like,
but that they have a
balanced personal life.
And one of the great decisions
I made was marrying Wendy,
and she did a lot
to keep me grounded.
She's the one that got me
interested in conservation
and I went on-- she served
on the board of the Nature
Conservancy, was a vice
chairman and chairman
of the New York and
Illinois chapters
and got me involved
there, got me involved
in many of the
things we've done.
And she's frugal.
She went to college
on a scholarship.
Her father was a
military officer.
She worked her way
through and she's generous
when it comes to
giving away money.
She does not like
to spend money,
and so that anecdote was
one of many I could've told.
But anyway, she--
during the crisis,
she was a great sense of support
and a strong sense of support.
MARY GROVE: Wonderful.
You've said in your
motivation to participate
in the documentary that you
felt it important to have
a historical record of what had
happened so that we don't play
this movie all over again.
Given Dodd-Frank
and other policy
changes, what do you think the
odds are that we do, in fact,
play this movie all over again?
HANK PAULSON: Well,
you're right in terms
of the lessons we
need to learn and I
am hopeful we won't play this
movie over again anytime soon.
If you were to ask me, are we
going to have financial crises?
Of course we're going to
have financial crises.
I don't care what
economic system you have,
how the financial system is
structured, how it's regulated.
As long as you have
banks and as long
as you have a financial
system, you're
going to have financial crises.
But most of them
have been manageable,
and manageable in so that they
can be handled in such a way,
and so it doesn't spill
over to the broader economy.
And so what we want
to do, is we want
to avoid massive disruptions.
The Great Depression-- which I
think we could very easily have
had something where we had
unemployment rivaling, or maybe
exceeding, the level of 25% we
had during the Great Depression
during the crisis
we went through.
And I think to avoid these
massive disruptions there's
two things that are important.
First, we really can't let
excesses build up to the point
that they've built
up, and so you
need to deal with
fundamental economic issues.
And to me the question to
really ask ourselves here
is, what policies give us
sustainable economic growth?
And those are going to
be the policies that
are going to give us
generational equity, that
are going to increase
our national security
and our economic security.
And I think the kinds
of policies we really
need to be fighting for are
all structural changes that
take bipartisan cooperation.
And so I'm talking
about policies
that help us manage our fiscal
problems in a balanced way,
while at the same
time we've got growth.
So we can't raise taxes too much
or cut so much that we really
undermine this
fledgling recovery.
And so what kinds of
things are we need?
I think we need tax reform,
we need entitlement reform,
we need immigration reform,
we need trade issues.
And one of the things
I'm proudest of
is that we worked as
well-- that when I say we,
it's Ben Bernanke,
Tim Geithner, and I--
I think we worked as well with
Democrats as with Republicans.
Congress twice acted before
we had real disaster.
We had policy continuity going
from the Bush administration
to the Obama administration
on these capital stabilization
programs.
So that's what you need
in the longer term.
On the short term, we need
to clean up our messes, OK,
the problems that led
to the last crisis,
and we need to make sure we have
the tools to manage a crisis
when it comes along.
Now in terms of
cleaning up the messes,
the thing that I
think we did a lot,
and I think Dodd-Frank
gives us a lot
of the authorities we need.
For instance, we now
have the authorities
to wind down a failing financial
institution, even if it's not
a bank, tools we could have
used with Lehman Brothers.
So no institution should
be-- if they fail,
should be propped up
in their current form.
And so with Dodd-Frank,
we've now got this resolution
authority, we've got
banks are better managed,
much better
capitalized-- which is
the ultimate defense--
better regulated.
So my focus is
really on the housing
still because, as
I said, I think
the most important thing we
did was put Fannie and Freddie
into conservator-ship.
But if you look then, they
backstopped, they guaranteed,
about half of the residential
mortgages in this country.
Now-- and when we
did that, it never
dawned on me that we would keep
them in their current form.
Never in a hundred years.
I referred to it as a time out.
It was a flawed structure
behind those agencies,
so they need to
be phased out, we
need to figure out what they're
going to be replaced with.
Well today, the government-- if
you look at the FHA and Fannie
Freddie, and other
programs, is backstopping
almost half the
residential mortgages.
Which means the
government is setting
the price and terms,
not the markets.
And I think that's unacceptable.
But now they're coining
money, making billions
of dollars a year,
there in the budget.
And so any way to
deal with them,
to reform, which
needs to be done,
is going to have a budget cost.
So that needs to be done.
And then of course the
key, I think, to a crisis
is when we're
confronted by a crisis,
to have the tools you
need to manage it.
And we had a really flawed
regulatory structure
without the necessary
authorities.
I think now we've got
a lot of what we need,
but there's still
some big problems.
We still have five regulators
falling all over each other,
and competing with
each other, and that's
why it's been so hard
to implement Dodd-Frank.
And I don't think
that's a good thing.
Why we should have
a SEC and CFTC
just makes no
sense in the world.
One to regulate
the cash markets,
the other to regulate
the futures markets.
But by and large, I think
we've got more work to be done.
But I think there's been
a lot of progress made
and a lot of Americans
are still suffering,
and it's going to
take a while, I think,
for our economy to get back
where it needs to come back to.
But again, I think
even then some
of the problems
we're dealing with
are longer term
circular problems that
aren't going to
be fixed until we
get some fundamental reforms.
Because even during,
for instance,
the 10 bubble years before the
crisis, where Americans were
doubling their borrowings to
maintain a standard of living
they couldn't afford,
you saw median income
was flat in this country.
And that's a sign of
declining competitiveness.
And in some of the
fundamental issues
we're dealing with, I'll
say this knowing that I'm
in Silicon Valley--
and technology,
is great we need it--
but I will tell you
technology and globalization
are killing jobs.
And you name the industry,
and almost any industry,
and every time I hear
of something new that's
being developed which is going
to improve all of our lives,
it's going to mean that
there are less jobs.
And I can give you
all kinds of examples,
so I think that's
another case where
we need to be working
on training programs
and preparing people to live
in the world that all of us
are going to be living
in in the future.
MARY GROVE: So speaking
of globalization,
you have kept a
pretty low profile
since leaving
government, and I'd
love to hear more
about what you've
been up to for the
last five years.
I understand you're working
on releasing a new book called
Dealing With China,
that you've traveled
to China over 80 times.
Talk to us about
your perspective
on this globalization,
specifically
with the view towards
your work in China.
HANK PAULSON: Well I'd say,
so Mary, the two things--
I do not for profit work.
So I have-- and I'm
interested in conservation
and the environment and
sustainability issues.
So I've got one thing
I won't talk about,
but which is a Latin
American Conservation
Council with a good
number of-- 35 CEOs,
a lot of them in Latin America--
focused on conservation issues
there-- water security,
saving the watershed,
smart infrastructure
development, and food security.
And then in China, we have the
Paulson Institute's roughly 20
people-- five in Beijing, people
in Washington, and in Chicago
at the University of Chicago.
I refer to it as a
think and do tank,
and I happen to think that
some of the major issues that
challenge us right now
are taking place in China.
The next 300 million
people going to the cities
will drive economic and
environmental outcomes
for China and for the
rest of the world.
They have some big opportunities
and some very, very big
challenges, and so the
sorts of programs we work on
are programs that have to do a
sustainable urbanization, work
on conservation
programs, leadership--
because I also think another
big development in the next 25
years will be major
Chinese companies going
out and becoming
global companies.
And their behaviors and
their governance systems,
and their environmental
practices,
training, hiring practices,
will make a big difference
throughout the world.
And so that's how
we spend our time
and I'm going through--
hopefully getting
near finishing a book on China,
which will hopefully come out
later this year, on China.
MARY GROVE: So
following up on that,
just to go back to
the film for a second.
You talked about-- in
those moments on the brink
when you knew that a run
on the money markets,
for example, would lead to
a collapse of the US market
in a matter of hours,
which in a matter of days
would lead to the collapse
of global financial markets.
In light of your
comments about China
and the global economy
being knit together,
do you think that the
balance of power is shifting?
Are there other
major economic player
to keep an eye on who could have
such an impact in the future?
HANK PAULSON: First of all,
obviously, for some time
there's been a trend
which is that a increasing
percentage of the economic
activity and economic growth
is taking place away from the
developed and Western world.
Now these developing countries--
some of these major developing
countries-- have got plenty
of challenges on their own
as we have seen recently, as
you've watched what's happening
in countries like India, Brazil,
Russia, and of course China
has got plenty of
their challenges.
And right now they have--
the new leadership team
is early in their tenure.
They have an economic
model that has clearly
run out of gas, that
needs to change.
It's going to be very
difficult for them
to do the things
they need to do.
They're a strong
leadership team,
but there's also strong vested
interest against-- they'll
be opposing reforms
and greater opening up.
I've been one that has
been cautiously optimistic
that China will do well
over-- in the years
ahead, just simply because their
leaders understand the problems
and they have a
lot of strengths.
But I would again say that
those jobs are tough jobs.
So I would, as
you look at China,
I would say that the new
leadership team-- coming out
of their third Plenum, which
is where they put forward
their platform for
their time in office--
have given themselves
a longer period of time
to put some of these
reforms in place.
And they've got
they're hands full
but I think they
will ultimately have
a good chance of
being successful.
But I think what this
means for all the rest
of us is that, in this
world that's increasingly
interconnected, I
think we're going
to expect to see
continued volatility
and I think we are going to see
continuing opportunities also
for global businesses,
because-- and I think
when you look at the rule
that a company like Google
plays in bringing
people together,
I think it's a very
important function.
MARY GROVE: Thank you.
In about three or
four minutes, we'll
shift gears and take
audience questions,
so if you have questions, if
you can go ahead and line up
at the microphone we'll
switch over a few minutes.
But speaking of Google, Hank.
We are at Google today.
I understand you had a chance to
demo Google Glass this morning.
Is that true?
working hear your thoughts.
Do you think in a few years
you could see traders wearing
Google Glass the
floor of the exchange?
HANK PAULSON: Well I
would-- let me say this.
I'm looking forward to
doing this afterwards,
so I didn't get a
chance yet this morning.
MARY GROVE: We'll
do it over lunch.
HANK PAULSON: We'll do it over
lunch and I look forward to it.
But I'll tell you
one thing I do know,
and you're talking
to someone who
is a Luddite when it
comes to using devices.
So I'm still at the stage
where iPhones and iPads and--
MARY GROVE: What is
your phone of choice?
HANK PAULSON: What?
MARY GROVE: What mobile
phone do you use?
HANK PAULSON: I started
off with a BlackBerry
because I could feel the
keys, and so now I've
advanced to an iPhone.
But the one thing I will
say in terms of markets.
I think there's a
lot more that can
be done in terms of
technology and markets.
And I think markets are,
when properly regulated
and structured, are hugely
And speaking about China,
with the new leadership team in
China has said very powerfully,
is they recognize
that markets have
got to play a
bigger role, by far.
The government
playing a lesser role.
And they cited all the examples
where the government has
been involved, and you've
got excess capacity,
whether it's steel
or shipbuilding,
you could just go through
industry and industry,
and they see the private sector.
And so I think-- and
so I have no doubt
that technology is
going to continue
to be a powerful
force in markets.
But it's also something we
need to understand better,
because with technology
and the upside
comes some very real risks.
MARY GROVE: Some great
responsibilities.
HANK PAULSON: Yep.
MARY GROVE: Question.
MALE SPEAKER: Everybody's
looking for the next crisis.
About 10 to 15 years ago, I
read this book by Frank Partnoy,
it's called "Fiasco," which
talks about derivatives.
And I remember he talks about a
lot of stuff that will blow up
in 2016, 2017, 2015, some bet
that Morgan Stanley or somebody
else has made at the
time with some company
in the world or
some pension fund.
So I was wondering
whether you think
there is a real issue
with this, and if there
is, what can be done about it?
HANK PAULSON: Well interesting
that you raise a question
because when I
talked about that,
alluded to this
first session I had
with President Bush
and his advisors
and we talked about
a financial crisis,
I talked about derivatives
because the complexity--
it's just like technology,
with anything--
you don't get in trouble
in financial markets
if you've got a bad idea.
Because it doesn't go anywhere.
You have trouble when you
get too much of a good idea.
And whether it's
securitization or derivatives.
And at the time when
I went to Washington,
we had a problem
because everyone
knew how much-- if
you're looking at debt,
let's say General Motors' debt.
You know how many bonds
they had outstanding.
But nobody knew how
many derivatives
had been written
against that debt.
A number of
institutions-- trades
weren't being settled
sometimes for six,
nine months after
they were made.
And it was very, very
hard for the industry
to figure out how
to clean it up,
because it took
their counterparts--
when I was at Goldman
Sachs I had begun
working on this with
the New York Fed.
Now I think today,
we've come a long way
and I'm much less focused
on the derivative problem
because there's a-- if
you look at Dodd-Frank,
there's a requirement
that derivatives be traded
on either exchanges or
central clearinghouses.
I don't like the way
it's been watered down,
in the sense with certain
derivatives being exempted.
I think what you really want
to do with derivatives is have
greater transparency and
so if you can't put them
on an exchange or
in a clearinghouse,
and they're so complex
they can't go there,
then you've got to get them
with a big capital charge.
Because complexity is enemy.
But I think there's been--
I should have given you
a much shorter
answer and just say
there's been a lot done
to deal with this problem.
So I think the things
that have got the most
focus-- the big banks, and
too big to fail-- sure,
that's still an issue, but
much better capitalized, better
regulated.
There are now emergency
authorities to deal with them.
The derivatives-- a lot has been
done with the derivatives area.
A lot more is being done.
So the things that I'm
tending to focus on
are the problems were there
hasn't been as much done--
Fannie or Freddie, or some
of the shadow banking market.
Looking at-- still the
commercial paper issue.
The SEC's got proposals, but
I'd like to see them enacted,
and I'm not sure
it's gone far enough.
MALE SPEAKER: What are your
thoughts on moral hazard?
HANK PAULSON: That's
one of the things
that the documentary does
a pretty good job on.
I think moral hazard is a
really important issue--
and for those of you, I think
you all pretty much know
what moral hazard is-- which
is, if there's a presumption
that the government's going to
be there to bail someone out,
then you're not going to have
all of the other stakeholders,
the shareholders the
borrowers, the depositors,
aren't going to be as
vigilant as they need to do.
Now as we went through
the financial crisis,
I was forced to do things that
wasn't really hard to decide
to do them, that we're
very objectionable,
but they're better
than the alternative.
In other words, there's
a moral hazard when
the government steps
in, but the alternative
is taking the system down and
everybody suffers even more
than they have.
Now I will say that
as I look back,
I don't think
there are many CEOs
of failed institutions
that wanted
the other institutions
fail, or are didn't suffer.
And if you look at what was
done with AIG and Fannie
or Freddie in terms of
management being replaced,
parachutes going, et cetera.
But to cut to the
chase, with moral hazard
I think one good
way to think about
is this: no matter how
well a regulatory system is
structured, we can
never rely on regulation
to solve all the problems.
It just won't.
Unless you believe the banks are
trying to blow themselves up,
it's hard to believe that
the regulators are always
going to find
problems that bankers
couldn't find themselves.
And so that's why you
need-- because of that,
you really should be
concerned about moral hazard,
and you really need
market discipline.
And so to me, the key thing
is we want to have the tools
so that when an
institution fails
you're not propping it
up in its current form.
And I think the
reason so much of what
we did was unpopular is
even though it-- putting
a cap on the banks prevented
failure, the money came back
that we put in, came
back plus $32 billion--
but because people don't want
to see institutions propped up
in their current form.
And so because moral hazard
is as important as it is.
I think is very
important that we always
maintain market discipline.
But during the crisis, I
might have-- moral hazard
wasn't the number
one thing in my mind.
Preventing disaster was
the number one thing.
MALE SPEAKER: One thing about
the crisis that was clear
as it was unfolding is that it
brought both parties together.
I mean, TARP
couldn't have gotten
through if Democrats
and Republicans weren't
working alongside each other.
As you were talking through
some of the things that
need to happen to
prevent future crises,
bipartisanship came
out of your mouth,
and I'm wondering if
you look at Washington,
you look at the way things
are going right now,
if you're concerned at all
that fighting between the two
parties prevents things like
immigration reform, which
you touched on, or [INAUDIBLE]?
HANK PAULSON: Well, I've thought
a lot about that because I
don't-- I've never been partisan
and the one thing that I could
not stand, and never
been able to stand,
is ideologues or people
who say, I know I'm right,
and we're only going
to do it my way,
and we're not going
to compromise.
And I had a-- one of the things
that was very important to me
when I came to Washington was
having the authority to replace
and choose my team, and choose
my team regardless of party.
And then had a president that
really, not only allowed me,
but encouraged me to
work across the aisle.
So I just-- and I'll
answer your question,
but when I-- the interesting
change in my thinking
between the time I wrote the
book on the financial crisis,
called On The Brink, and
the time I participated
in this documentary, was at
the time I wrote the book,
right afterwards,
it just seemed to me
like I couldn't believe Congress
took so long to act twice
when we're on the precipice.
I now look at it and say, twice!
We got these
incredible authorities,
and working across
party lines twice,
people made votes that they knew
was going to be very unpopular.
Everybody that voted, unless you
had your head screwed on wrong,
knew it was going
to be unpopular.
But when I came to Washington,
President Bush's approval
rating was 28%.
It was a poisonous
atmosphere and we
had time to get in
the trenches and work.
So today, it's
even more poisonous
and I've asked myself why.
Why is it?
And I think there are certain
structural issues when
you look at the extent to which
we've had this redistricting
and gerrymandering, which I
look at as in some ways almost
political corruption, where
80% of the seats in the House
are safe for one
party or the other,
so you're worried about
attack from either the left
or the right.
And so the fastest
way to lose your job,
if you're in
Congress, is to move
to the middle and
compromise with someone.
You look at the way people
get their news on blogs today.
My friends that are on
the far right, they all
talk to each other, they listen
to the same set of facts.
On the left, they've
got their own facts.
And remember,
members of Congress
reflect the voting public.
That's their job security.
But having said all that,
I still think our system is
the best of the world, and
I've-- it was alluded to.
I was in the Nixon White House.
I joined in April of '72, six
weeks before the Watergate
break-in.
So I witnessed that,
and so you talk
about poisonous atmosphere.
So I've got to tell
you, people that
say it's more poisonous
than they've ever seen
don't know their history,
and even going back further.
So I think what it takes
is strong leadership,
it takes strong leadership
from the president,
because he or she will
be the one person--
and some day it'll be
a she-- and are there
to represent all the people.
And then it's just going to take
working hard across the aisle,
and I tell you, you can't
do anything this important
really important
in Congress that's
structural without
bipartisanship.
MARY GROVE: Thank you.
So we currently have
about five minutes left.
If I could ask a favor of
our four colleagues to each
ask their questions in
a row, and then Hank,
if you can make general remarks.
HANK PAULSON: MALE SPEAKER:
You are so polite and nice.
What you mean to say is, ask
a favor-- please be brief.
That's not one of my virtues.
MARY GROVE: No, no.
You can ask them in
a row, and maybe you
can make some general remarks.
HANK PAULSON: I'll try okay.
MALE SPEAKER: So one of
the benefits of free market
capitalism versus the
crony capitalism version
that we currently have-- and
a lot of the programs help--
is that there's a good
side effect to failure
of a commercial
enterprise, is that whoever
emerges from the ashes
learns their lesson.
HANK PAULSON: Yep.
MALE SPEAKER: And
if we'd done this
during LTCM the current
crisis wouldn't have happened.
But we didn't do
anything for these guys
to learn the lessons.
Couldn't we have
attached a condition
to the recapitalization that's
limiting bonus, something
that someone would
have, at least,
would have learned
their lessons.
HANK PAULSON: I got it.
MALE SPEAKER: I
just wanted to know
what you believe
poses the biggest risk
today to bring about a
future financial crisis.
HANK PAULSON: OK.
MALE SPEAKER:
Something different
than financial crises.
I wanted your thoughts
on banking rules
and how they relate to
the recent legalization
of marijuana in
Washington and Colorado,
and whether there's
a way for those rules
to be adjusted so
those states can
make their democratic
experiment,
or would that be
a loophole that's
too dangerous for the
system as a whole?
FEMALE SPEAKER: What are your
thoughts on that Bitcoins,
and should I put
all my money in it?
[LAUGHTER]
HANK PAULSON: What's that?
I missed it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: On Bitcoins.
HANK PAULSON: Oh, Bitcoins.
OK.
So, this is going to be--
these are going to be easy
because there's two
questions I can answer.
There's two I don't really
have terrific answers for,
but so let me
start with the two.
First of all, on the
question I-- one question,
the idea whether the
documentary, which
is, I think a
terrific question--
is the one about
capitalizing the banks,
and why weren't we harsher?
And again, I believe that
institutions, when they fail,
they should bear
the consequences.
But financial
institutions, in the middle
of a crisis-- let me say, no
bank is too big to liquidate.
Almost any bank is too
big to liquidate quickly
in the middle of a
crisis, any bank of size.
And I think what people didn't
understand about our capital
program is that traditionally
what has been done
is, during a crisis when
an institution fails,
you nationalize it.
And when you
nationalize it, then you
can have all kinds
of restrictions
you can place on it.
But we did something that
had never been done before,
that I can find in history.
Before institutions went
down, we went out very quickly
and we recapitalized
the banking system.
And if you don't do that-- and
we did with attractive terms.
If we had tough terms, banks
wouldn't take the capital
until they're ready to fail.
Everyone's the
tallest midget when
you're going through
something like that.
So what we did was
we did something,
and if you want to know
why our stress tests work,
why our financial
systems come back,
why our economies come
back better than Europeans,
it's because what
they did was they
were very tough with the terms,
but they nationalized them.
And so that's one of the
biggest reasons why what we did
was unpopular.
It's pretty hard
to punish and save
the banks at the
same time, and I
know that the
American public wanted
us to hold them accountable.
But I tilted toward
the sides of stability.
Now I've got to
tell you, in terms
of your question about marijuana
and the banking system,
I don't have a clue.
[LAUGHTER]
I've got a daughter--
the closest I am to it
is I got a daughter-- with
her husband and her kids-- who
lives in Boulder and
I was just skiing
with them over the weekend.
And the power was up
to here, it was great.
We were talking about what this
experiment is doing in Boulder.
We had quite a
family debate on it,
you can imagine looking at
me what side of the debate
I came down on.
[LAUGHTER]
But in any event.
I don't know.
In terms of the question
about what things
I'm most concerned about.
What I am most concerned about,
in terms of the obvious masses
that we haven't dealt with,
is Fannie and Freddie.
We haven't dealt with housing
policy in the United States.
And I'm not against
home ownership,
I'm all for home ownership.
But why is it fair
that any of us
could deduct interest on
a $1 million mortgage?
How is that fair to renters?
Why does that make sense?
And if you look at that, and
Fannie and Freddie, and the FHA
programs, when the government is
backing almost every mortgage,
then the markets aren't working.
And there's just not-- so
I'm concerned about that,
but I'm even more
concerned, longer term,
we need to put some
policies in place
that are going to give us
sustainable economic growth.
And in terms of the
Bitcoin, I think
you could probably find
it strange for someone
in my position-- I
haven't studied it.
I'm suspicious about it.
And maybe I just don't know
enough about it, but as I said,
I am for innovation in a whole
lot of areas, and for change.
When I ran Goldman
Sachs, all the time
I was just telling
people constantly how
they had to welcome change.
But when you look
at rapid change
when it comes to markets,
and when it comes to finance,
I think innovation
is something we
have to be very careful
about, because when you get
extreme volatility and when you
get either extreme volatility
or complexity, it can really
hurt people and undermine
their financial security.
So let's say this
is an amazing group
and you had terrific questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MARY GROVE: For
everyone in the room,
I really appreciate
you joining us,
and I highly encourage you
to check out the documentary
"Hank: 5 Years from the Brink."
It's available on Netflix,
and Secretary Paulson,
thank you for your
service to our country
and for joining us
at Google today.
HANK PAULSON: And
Mary, thank you.
This has been a lot easier
than a congressional hearing.
[LAUGHTER]
MARY GROVE: Good to hear.
[THEME MUSIC PLAYING]